hi i'm jack antonoff uh from bleachers
here with buzzfeed
to read thirst tweets let me just tell
my mother i'll be back should we get my
mother into this would that be like a
freudian nightmare an edible nightmare
which is the one that i'm thinking of
all
sort of philosophers and whatnot aside
it would be a nightmare to have my
mother read these so
let's jump in
i think i'm in love with jack antonoff
he's bleachers
and he's gorgeous two facts jackhand if
you ever fancy a date
hit me up pet oh i like that i'm
assuming this person is british
thank you tweet number two the
definition of yellow jack anton
off the definition of sunshine jack
antonoff's smile
at jack and knife your sunshine and we
love you so much i hope you're having an
amazing
day i don't get it the definition of
yellow is this some like lingo that i
don't understand
i would call this barely thirsty very
sweet barely thirsty i don't spend a lot
of time online so stuff i hear about is
so
egregiously thirsty and offensive that
these are kind of just washing over me
as
compliments all right i'm moving on
number three jack anthony's arms are the
most beautiful limbs to grace this earth
very nice still not that thirsty four i
could seriously look at that game so
stubble for 18 years and still want to
stare at it longer i assume you guys are
going to build to it
tweet number five i want to kiss the
brain of jack anthony can i just say
that i really
dislike saying my name over and over and
over again it's a very weird feeling
okay i want to kiss the brain of jack
antonoff because he is a
genius at making slash composing music
very sweet i was told to enjoy the sweet
ones while they last
knowing the internet there's probably
going to be some like okay moving on
jack antonoff and a cut-off is my
sexuality i appreciate that
you got to feel good especially when you
play music especially when you write
music you have to like feel yourself
in some ways i feel good in a tank top i
feel like my dad in the 80s jack
antonoff is my type he's
like the hot nerdy with big
type of a guy i thought it would either
say big energy or up big
but we can't know what this person's
thinking he's such an old soul but his
presence smells like
an addictive aroma oh my god hi i'll
tell you why i really like this tweet
you don't often see
someone you know referencing the
wholesome quality of an old soul and
a big and i think that's cool because i
think that's kind of real like i think
people either like lean
so overly sexual or like so sincere and
it's like i like someone who is
kind of being pretty real like i want an
old soul who also has a big
so this person i think is the first one
that really gets my vote next one
currently grounded for writing uh quote
if lost please return to jack antonoff
and all my underwear
makes sense well the underworld's being
dropped off at my house
opening shut case of this tweet number
nine jack antonov could ask
me to eat glass and i would say yes and
thank him for the opportunity
hot not not hot number 10 the way i
would let jack antonoff
crush me like a roach i've been there
i've had a crush from a distance and
just been like ah crush me
like a roach i like this one i like this
one a lot i um
can imagine being with this person
number 11 profession
a hole for jack antonoff sir checkmark
i'll say this when the lingo is like too
like sort of like culturally specific
it's less
shocking or thirsty to me you know if i
read that tweet in like 2012 i would be
like holy
that is one of the filthiest things i've
ever read but it's just become
so commonplace you know kind of the way
like choke me had like you know
sometimes if you just happen to go on
twitter it's just we've reached a point
culturally where like you know the
concept of being a hole for someone
choking someone or something like that
is just so in the lingo that
it's uh less shocking than the person
who called me an old soul my boyfriend
and i want to have a threesome with jack
anthony off someone let him know
consider me served
i decline but i respect the uh actually
i don't know
i can't know i like to be with one
person typically and it's just
it's just a personal preference i don't
like more than one person
around for anything really but you and
your boyfriend seem to have a really
nice you know as long as he's in on this
tweet then i think that's really great
for you guys
i would let jack anthony suffocate me
with his legs well this is interesting
i don't like the image yeah i don't like
this one i'm moving on
i would let jack antonoff know that any
time he feels like
filling a hole spelled with the big zero
instead of the little o
or two i'll be waiting with open arms
open legs in an open
mouth to thank him for his service this
is a lot of layers to this one just like
the person who called me an old soul in
the big
tweet the imagery of open arms is so
wholesome
and then thanking me for my service
feels sort of
wholesome and american and obviously you
know verbage that we use for the troops
um what i'm noticing with some of these
thirsty tweets
is a real play back and forth between
like hyper wholesome
and hyper filthy to throw in there that
i could you know
fill this h-o-l-e
et cetera and that the invitation is
being waited on with open arms
and then to thank one for their service
is uh regal
anyway i would let jack anthony put it
in the
butt i love lady gaga i think she's a
really interesting artist this is by
far my favorite one i think this is the
kind of tweet that's worth signing on
for
one time someone tweeted at me my
favorite thing i've ever seen and it
made me feel like it was worth it to to
go online here there
you bear a great russian name but act as
a pervert and a jew
comma who are you question mark and i
just think it's like a brilliant
composition
tweets no different than poems essays or
novels
need to be judged within their mediums
this tweet that i'm reading right here
has a similar energy it almost touches
the broadness of the internet
the randomness of life and the human
brain of just being able to move
and vacillate so quickly between things
i feel more connected to this
tweet than any of the other ones i've
read just in terms of the flow of
information i got two more i would suck
the sweat off
uh jackets an awesome ballsack a little
clinical for me
it's interesting the things you do and
don't want from the internet because
this is too clinical this feels too
conversational but then if it feels too
internet
feels too performative you know all the
use of holes and choking is a little too
internet but this is a little too
you know i don't know tell your
therapist here we go damn jack antonov
come
produce this it's spelled with a b is
this slang
blessy can you guys tell me about this
slang i don't like it oh it's a boy
[ __ ]
oh i haven't heard this i do like it
interesting okay so damn jack and stuff
come produce this [ __ ] i like that it
brings
um the work that means a lot to me into
the equation i feel
well liked and seen sexually i like this
one because
i think this so this is sort of sitting
right in the middle of what i was hoping
for right it's not too clinical like i
would suck so and so
and it's not too internet like you know
like come fill these holes you know
daddy or whatever my album is out
usually i mentioned people
listening to it and sort of going on
that journey but i think this audience
that i've been speaking to through these
tweets might be on a different journey
which i'm also hip to you could spend
time with the album or we could spend
more time in this i guess unconscious
fantasy conversation that's happening
and yeah thank you for your service
[Music]